ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU
CHAVEZ CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
[inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DAILY.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER XENA GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES RELY LESS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND TING VOEPEL WALDRON
WEBER WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REPETITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. TWO WEEKS AGO. ONE
HUNDRED AND THREE PASSENGERS AND
CREW SURVIVED THE CRASH OF THEIR
PLANE SHORTLY AFTER TAKEOFF FROM
DURANGO MEXICO.
ALTHOUGH NINETY SEVEN WERE
INJURED.
THERE WERE AMAZINGLY NO
FATALITIES.
A FEW DAYS AGO I LISTEN TO THE
AN INTERVIEW ON NPR.
WITH WEATHER WITH THE FORTUNATE
PASSENGERS.
THE INTERVIEWER ASKED IF THIS
EXPERIENCED HAD CHANGED HIS
LIFE.
I HAVE LITTLE DOUBT THAT HIS
RESPONSE WAS ONE THAT RESONATED
DEEPLY WITH EVERYONE WHO WAS
LISTENING.
SHE SAID THAT. TOO OFTEN WE JUST
TAKE FOR GRANTED OUR EVERYDAY
LIFE.
WE WORRY AND EVEN DISPARITIES
HIME SOBRE THINGS THAT ARE JUST
MATERIAL POSSESSIONS.
HE THEN ADDED.
THAT ALTHOUGH HE HAS ALWAYS
TRIED.
HE MUST TRY TO LIVE WITH MORE
LOVE IN HIS LIFE.
HE ENCOURAGED WE MUST ALL LIVE
WITH MORE LOVE IN OUR LIVES.
ALL PEOPLE WE MUST CARE FOR EACH
OTHER MORE DEEPLY.
AND NOT TAKE FOR GRANTED A
SINGLE DAY.
CLEARLY HIS WISDOM EYES WERE
WIDE OPEN.
AND HE'S GOING TO TRY ITS VERY
BEST TO KEEP THEM OPEN FROM NOW
ON WITH WISDOM EYES OPEN.
WE NEED TO REMEMBER TO LIVE WITH
LOVE IN OUR LIVES AND NOT TAKE
FOR GRANTED A SINGLE DAY.
NOW MORE MEDIA WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AS SHE LEAVES
US IN THE PLEDGE MS COMMODO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE READY BEGAN
[inaudible]
YES BLACK [inaudible]
STATES [inaudible] ZERO SAN.
IT IS [inaudible]
DNS.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JULY 262018%
OF THE PROVISIONS OF TRAVEL
FIFTY NINE THE FOLLOWING
ASSEMBLY JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REGULAR
SESSION WAS PRINTED WELL THAT'S
CERTAINLY WASN'T SUMMER
REASSURED CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS HAVE THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S.
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
WE TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN DALLY.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY VOEPEL
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW SOMEONE.
CHOI COOLEY GLORIA IRWIN KALRA
AND SALAS TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BLOOM ACOSTA BAKER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND PATTERSON TO
SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE S. B. NINETY
SEVEN GALGIANI.
ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE SB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SENATOR
TRANSPORTATION BY DAVID CHIU
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR SP TWELVE
SEVENTY FOUR MCGUIRE BY RUBIO.
AND ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX JACKSON BY
LIMON.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE RE REFER ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT THROUGH ITEM
SIXTY THREE TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THE BILLS ARE SB EIGHT
FORTY TWO S. B. A FORTY THREE SB
EIGHT FORTY FOUR S. B. EIGHT
FORTY FIVE S. B..
EIGHT FORTY SIX AND S. B..
EIGHT SIXTY ONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN AB TWENTY FORTY FOUR
STONE TO THE SENATE.
CLERK WILL NOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS I
AM GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM A FOR S.
B. ONE SIXTY FIVE PORTANTINO.
AN ITEM A TWENTY FOUR S. B.
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR LEYVA.
CLERK WILL AGAIN NOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
ONE S. B. TEN FIFTY FOUR
HERTZBERG FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND MOVE THE BILL TO
THE INACTIVE FILE.
AGAIN THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
ROLE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I AM REFERRING TO THE
FOLLOWING BILL TO COMMITTEE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX A. B.. TWENTY
NINE TWENTY THURMAN TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE GUESTS.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER OF MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY THE
TOP FOR FINISHING TEAMS.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CYBER
INNOVATION CHALLENGE AS YOU KNOW
WE HAVE QUITE A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE IN THE AREA OF CYBER
SECURITY SO TO SEE.
ALL THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
EXCELLING.
WARMS MY HEART.
THE CHALLENGE IS SPONSORED BY
GOBIZ THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CAL POLLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND TOOK PLACE THIS PAST
JUNE ON CALIFORNIA'S CAMPUS.
IT BRINGS TOGETHER TEAMS OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE. TO WORK AS DIGITAL
FORENSICS INVESTIGATORS AND
RESPOND TO A CYBER ATTACK.
THE TEAMS JOINING US TODAY ARE
AND MAYBE YOU COULD WAVE WHEN I
CALL YOUR TEAM.
CENTENNIAL HIGH SCHOOL FROM
BAKERSFIELD [inaudible]
JUST WEBSITE.
JESUIT HIGH SCHOOL FROM
SACRAMENTO.
NORTH HOLLYWOOD HIGH SCHOOL FROM
LOS ANGELES.
AND DEL NORTE HIGH SCHOOL FROM
SAN DIEGO.
QUICKLY USE COACHES AND CAPTAINS
OVER THE TEAM COACHES AND
CAPTAINS ARE IN THE REAR THE
GALLERY AND A REAL ART REAR THE
CHAMBER AND THE REST OF THE
GALLERY AS YOU SEE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE CYBERSECURITY
CHAMPION CALIFORNIA STATE
MEMBERS WE HAVE ATTENTION.
MISTER GLORIA YOU HAVE SPECIAL
GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER --
THIS WEEK I RISE ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY GREAT COLLEAGUE
DOCTOR WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE SOME VERY IMPORTANT
LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL
COMMUNITY.
OF THESE TRIBAL LEADERS ARE WITH
US TO HEAR TO PROMOTE THE FIFTY
FIRST ANNUAL NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
IN TRIBAL LEADERS FORM WHICH BE
TAKING PLACE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL.
OF THE LAST WEEK OF SEPTEMBER
NOW AS MANY OF YOU KNOW NATIVE
AMERICAN DAYS AN ANNUAL
TRADITION DESIGNED TO PROMOTE
THE HISTORY AND THE CULTURE OF
NATIVE AMERICANS.
THIS YEAR'S THEME IS LOOKING
TOWARD THE FUTURE TRIBAL STATE
RELATIONSHIPS IT AIMS TO FOCUS
ON WAYS TO STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S RELATIONSHIP WITH
ITS MANY SOVEREIGN GOVERNMENTS
WITHIN OUR STATE'S BORDERS.
MEMBERS OF THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF OF LEADERS
WHO ARE HERE I'M GLAD TO GET IN
POSITION.
I WE HAVE A CHAIRMAN --
GARTH STEINBERG OF THEIR
TRINIDAD MANCHURIA AND CHAIRMAN
RUSSELL BUSTER ADDERBURY WITH
THE CAR COULD TRIBE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BOTH OF WHOM ARE REPRESENTING
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN'S ASSOCIATION.
FROM THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL PERSONS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE CHAIRMAN MICHAEL HUNTER OF
THE COYOTE VALLEY BAND APOLLO
INDIANS.
AND CHAIRMAN RICHARD HIT
HITCHCOCK OF THE WILL TO
MANCHURIA.
AND FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
MISTER SPEAKER WE HAVE THE
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN.
FROM THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL CHAIRMAN'S ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE MY FRIEND CHAIRMAN BOMIS
EDDIE OF THE RINCON.
BAND OF THE SAME YEAH INDIANS
AND ALSO MY DEAR FRIEND
CHAIRWOMAN ERICA PINTO --
WE WOULD LIKE TO INVITE ALL OF
YOU TO JOIN US ON NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY AND THAT THE TRIBAL
LEADERS FORM AGAIN WHICH WILL BE
HELD THE LAST WEEK OF SEPTEMBER.
MEMBERS WOULD YOU PLEASE JOIN ME
IN DOCTOR WOULD AND ANA
WELCOMING OUR HONORED GAS AND
PLEASE JOIN US FOR A BRIEF
RECEPTION HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
THE WILLIE BROWN.
BAKER
CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE OFFICE PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS IN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE S. B.
TWELVE ANYONE STERN AND ITEM ONE
NINETY THREE SB THIRTY SIX FIVE
HUESO.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM ELEVEN AB FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE LACKEY FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL AGAIN NO.
I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION
.
COLLEAGUES AT THIS TIME WE ARE
RECORD SEEN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CLASS OF
ASSEMBLY FELLOWS.
I ASK FOR QUIETED THE CHAMBER
AND ATTENTION DIRECT TO THE
FRONT OF OUR CHAMBERS.
DURING THEIR ELEVEN MONTH TENURE
WITH US.
THE ASSEMBLY FELLOWS HAVE
SERVICE IN A WIDE RANGE OF STAFF
FUNCTIONS REPORTING THE WORK OF
THIS LET'S SAY BODY.
NEARLY HALF OF THE OFFICES IN
THE LITERATURE APPOINT FORMER
FELLOWS AT THIS TIME.
FROM THE EXECUTIVE JUDICIAL
SENATE OR SIMPLY FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAMS.
OTHER PASSED FELLOWS ARE NOW
MEMBERS ARE OFFICERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
A SERVICE GVERNMENT OFFICIALS
THEY SIT ON THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT.
THEY OUR UNIVERSITY INSTRUCTORS
EXECUTIVES AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
FROM THIS ROLE WHICH WE HONOR
TODAY THEY GO ON TO DO A GREAT
MANY THINGS.
SHAPE THE FUTURE OF OUR GREAT
STATE.
I ASK A SILLY.
AS SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON A
PROGRAM FOR ILLEGAL [inaudible]
MARIE WALDRON. TO EXTEND
HOSPITALITY TO OUR FELLOWS IN
DUE COURSE.
AS WE RECEIVE THEM IN THE CENTER
AISLE.
SO COLLEAGUES AND GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT.
TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN JESSE MARVIN ON ROOM
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY FELLOWS.
OR FOR RECOGNITION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY IS PEUGEOT NOBODY
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UC IRVINE
.
SUPPORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN ELIZABETH SMITH.
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UC SANTA
BARBARA
[inaudible]
WELL
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA IS EDWIN SAUCEDO HE'S A
GRADUATE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU IS SAMANTHA WHEN SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS
.
ACCORDING TO BUY SOMETHING FLORA
IS LUCAS WEBSTER HE'S A GRADUATE
OF YALE UNIVERSITY
.
ESCORTED BY SOME REMEMBER FONG
IS ZERO ZERO IT'S ABOUT MEN SHE
IS A GRADUATE AT CSU LONG BEACH
.
ESCORTED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
GALLAGHER IS DAVID EVANS THE
SECOND HE IS A GRADUATE OF CSU
SACRAMENTO
.
ESCORTED BY SOME A MEMBER GLORIA
IS UPON YOU
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN IS LUCIUS OUT OF
OUR SHE IS A GRADUATE OF BERNARD
COLLEGE AT COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
.
ESCORTED BY SOME A MEMBER JONES
SAWYER IS REGGIE JOHNSON HE IS A
GRADUATE OF UC MERCED
[inaudible]
THEY
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KILEY IS CREATE ABOVE.
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY IS AMANDA HERNANDEZ SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LA
MODE IS BEYONCE OR IS A GRADUATE
OF UC SANTA CRUZ
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
IS ANY FRANCO HE'S A GRADUATE OF
UC RIVERSIDE
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
IS AMR RASHEED IS A GRADUATE OF
WHAT YOUR COLLEGE
.
ESCORTED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
SANTIAGO IS GABRIELA CHRISTY OUT
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UCLA
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER
IS TO PEOPLE IF SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF SEE IF YOU SAN
MARCOS
.
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON ELISABETH AND YASSER SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS
.
AT THIS TIME OR QUESTIONS PLEASE
DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
WE ARE PLEASED TODAY TO WELCOME
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS.
THE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO TO
ROBERT NELSON.
JOINING HIM IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT PUBLIC POLICY PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND ADVOCACY FOR CSU
SACCHAROMYCES TO FILL GARCIA.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA SAYS MS
LEONA ELAINE.
THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
CONFEDERATION VERSUS YOU
SACRAMENTO MISTER NATAN
DIETRICH.
AND ALSO THE INIMITABLE DIRECTOR
OF THE ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM MISS PAM CHIU WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE CHAMBERS.
THIS DAY.
WE ALSO WELCOME THE OTHER STAFF
FROM THE CENTER FOR CAL FOR
STUDIES.
PARENTS FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO
ARE WITH US IN THE GALLERY.
WELCOME TO THE CHAMBERS.
THERE WILL BE A RECEPTION IN
HONOR OF THE FELLOWS IN THE
RECALL ROOM THAT WILL
[inaudible]
IMMEDIATELY [inaudible]
PART [inaudible]
AND AGAIN WE WELCOME THEM TO THE
FLOOR.
THEN CONCLUDE YOUR PICTURES
[inaudible]
BACKGROUND [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT.
STINGERS UP BUT WE WOULD NOT
STRENGTHENING ELSE PRESIDENT
NELSON.
AT THIS TIME IS PRESENT NELSON
AND THE FELLOWS EXIT THE
CHAMBER.
I'D ASK YOU TO PLEASE STAND TO
GIVE
.
IN THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
THEY MEMBERS WE ARE NOT GOING TO
MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
WE ARE AT SECOND READING.
CORKERY.
CYNICAL FOURTEEN TEN TEN OF
SEVEN AND TEN SEVENTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT CONCURRENCE.
HIS CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEMS. FOUR AND
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SIX IS AB TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN BY MISTER TANG CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER TING
ACTUALLY THE TENANCY.
MISTER TANG.
THEY YOU BUT SPEAKER AB TWENTY
TWO NINETEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE BILL AS SURE AS
I READ PAYMENTS CAN BE MADE BY A
THIRD PARTY WITH.
OUR WRITTEN STE PROTECTIONS FOR
A LANDLORD MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE WERE
MADE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MS TANK SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LOCAL WRENN MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIME ABOUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM SEVEN IS AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY THE MENTAL HEALTH.
DOCTOR WEBER YES MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWELVE FIFTEEN IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE IN CHANGES OFF THE SHIP.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR OF VOTE ON CONCURRENCE ON
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RUN.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT AB AT THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MISTER SALAS
[inaudible]
QUICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH [inaudible]
MISTER SALAS.
THINK IT WAS BIGGER MEMBERS THAT
THIS BILL DEALS WITH VALLEY
FEVER I THINK I'VE SPOKEN TO
EVERY MEMBER ON THIS FLOOR --
EXTENSIVELY OF NOT PERSONALLY
ABOUT EACH OF THESE CASES SENATE
AMENDMENTS JUST PROVIDE SUNSET
THAT WERE SUNSET DATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
NAMES SALAS SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE RIDE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM.
NINE AND TEN FILE ITEMS NINE AND
TEN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN MEMBERS
IS A FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN SALAS
CLERK WILL READ.
S. UNABLE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SOME A MEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS IN ATLANTA COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES [inaudible]
MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU A SPEAKER AGAIN THIS
IS ANOTHER BILL DEALING WITH
VALLEY FEVER IS PART OF THE
VALLEY FEVER PACKAGE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
SENTIMENTS WERE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE.
AND THAT'S PRIVATE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR FALL.
I THINK MISTER SPEAKER I RISE A
PROUD GOING AUTHOR OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
FUNDAMENTAL MEASURE THAN SURE IS
CONSISTENCY AND IN VALLEY FEVER
CASE REPORTING.
THIS BILL REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO COLLECT DATA
ON VALLEY FEVER BY APRIL
FIFTEENTH OF EACH YEAR FROM CAL
READY IN ANY OTHER ELECTRONIC
DATA SYSTEMS.
I FEVER IS A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGE IN KERN COUNTY
AND THERE ARE SIGNS THAT IS
SPREADING TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE STATE
AND COUNTIES HAVE CONSISTENT AND
ACCURATE DATA ON VALLEY FEVER
CASES SO THAT WE MAY HAVE
PROPERLY RESPOND REVIVED
RESOURCES WHERE MOST NEEDED.
THIS YEAR WE MAY CONTINUE TO
PROGRESS IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
VALLEY FEVER AND ONE I THINK THE
KERN COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT.
IN THE VALLEY FEVER AMERICA'S
FOUNDATION FOR BRINGING THE LACK
OF DATA TRANSPARENCY TO MY
ATTENTION AND FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF IN CRAFTING THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL.
FIGHT AGAINST THIS DISEASE
REQUIRES OUR STATE AND LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVES TO WORK TOGETHER
TO BRING EVERY AVAILABLE
RESOURCE THE HEALTH AUTHORITIES
FIGHTING VALLEY FEVER THE FRONT
LINES EACH AND EVERY DAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I THOUGH
[inaudible]
THINGS FALL.
SAME NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLICK WELL ABOVE THE ROLE.
HE'S OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEMS TWELVE AND THIRTEEN
HOUSE RETAIN [inaudible]
FOLLOW.
FOURTEEN AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE
BY MISTER BERMAN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOME A MEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS
[inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE HOLLOW JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
TOPIC OF ELECTION CYBERSECURITY.
ONE OF THE RECURRING THEMES THAT
EMERGED DURING THE TESTIMONY OF
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS
THAT MAXIMIZING THE
CYBERSECURITY OF OUR STATES
ELECTIONS WON'T REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES DEDICATED
TO THAT PURPOSE.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE CREATES
THE OFFICE OF ELECTION
CYBERSECURITY WITHIN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
SINCE THE ASSEMBLY'S PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL THE STATE BUDGET
INCLUDED TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
ELECTION CYBERSECURITY.
THE BUDGET ACTION ALSO EXPANDED
THE SCOPE OF THE OFFICES DUTIES
TO INCLUDE MONITORING AND
COUNTERACTING FALSE OR
MISLEADING INFORMATION REGARDING
THE ELECTORAL PROCESS.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS TO AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE SIMPLY
BROADENED THE MISSION OF THE
OFFICE TO CONFORM TO THE ACTION
TAKEN AS PART OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE IS
SUPPORTED BY SECRETARY OF STATE
OUT EXPEDIA AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BYRNE MISTER
HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
PROTECTING OUR ELECTIONS FROM
HACKING IS IMPORTANT.
HOWEVER ADDING THIS NEW
GOVERNMENT AGENCY TO DO SO IS
NOT.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TESTIFIED
EARLIER THIS YEAR I TO THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE THAT.
KNEW THAT HE NEEDED MORE MONEY
TO BE ABLE REPLACE AGING VOTING
MACHINES BUT NOT A NEW AGENCY.
A EVEN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE
ACCORDING TO TESTIMONY AT THAT
SAME COMMITTEE.
WINDOWS WERE IN A SUMMER
ALLEGING THAT RUSSIA HAD MEDDLED
IN OUR ELECTIONS IT WAS
TESTIFIED THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTION SYSTEM HAD NOT BEEN
COMPROMISE NOT ONE VOTE HAD BEEN
CHANGED.
WE DO NOT NEED OUT OF THE
BUREAUCRACY TO CHECK TO PROTECT
OUR ELECTION SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY SPECIFIC TO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS WE SHOULD NOT
GIVE THE SECRETARY OF STATE THE
AUTHORITY TO DECIDE SUBJECTIVELY
WHAT IS FALSE OR MISLEADING
INFORMATION ELECTION.
IF INDEED THIS WAS ABOUT MAKING
SURE TO AVOID SITUATIONS IN
WHICH SOMEONE WAS GIVING WRONG
INFORMATION ABOUT NGUYEN TO VOTE
HOW TO VOTE EX ACTOR.
THEN IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SPECIFICALLY AND NARROWLY
TAILORED TO THAT BUT WHAT THIS
EQUATES TO IS BEING ABLE TO
FRANK DURING THE ELECTION PERIOD
FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
IS NOT.
ONLY THIS IS JUST AN
UNCONSCIONABLE AMENDMENT BECAUSE
WHAT THIS IS ASKING US TO DO IS
GET IN THE GO BEYOND OUR HAVING
A SITUATION WHICH THEY'RE
SIMPLY.
COLLECTING THE VOTES AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE ELECTIONS
ARE GOING SPECIFICALLY THE WAY
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO INTO HAVING.
A SUBJECTIVE OPINION.
CAMPAIGN ORIENTED COMMUNICATIONS
BEING ADDED INTO THE DEBATE INTO
THE ARENA AND TORE ELECTIONS
PROCESS.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE FOR A VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THAT THIS IS A BILL
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
SUPPORTS IT IS VERY NARROWLY
TAILORED. TO ONLY HAVE TO DO
WITH THE ELECTORAL PROCESS WHEN
IT IN WHEN IT I IN REGARDS TO
MISINFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THEY WISH BERMAN WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE RAINN ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
YOU DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL TIME ABOUT ICE
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN IS A BE.
SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER BONTA AND
ATLANTA CANNABIS DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY [inaudible]
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
ONE IS BACK.
TODAY FOR CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
IN THE SENATE ADDED AN URGENCY
BECAUSE TO THE BILL THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTESINOS
KASHER DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OF THIS OUT OF
THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY ABOUT ICE
FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN ON THE
URGENCY AYE AYES.
MEASURE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
IS AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE
CORPORATE.
AS A LEGAL TWENTY FORTY FIVE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE AND
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE
[inaudible]
MISTER DALY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ANNUAL
INSURANCE COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL.
IT MAKES A NUMBER OF NON
CONTROVERSY ALL TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
INSURANCE CODE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WHICH DALY SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
PHYLUM SEVENTEEN IS AB. TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TO BY DOCTOR WEBER.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER AND ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAIL BUT YES
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS --
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE.
OUR MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS
REFLECT OUR CONVERSATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO ENSURE PROPER IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL WHEN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS COMMENCES.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS AND HAS
NO OPPOSITION OUR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENT ON THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISTER
HARPER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
WHEN PRISONERS ARE COUNTED AS A
PART OF THE FEDERAL CENSUS THEY
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED WHERE
THEY'RE LIVING WHERE THE PRISON
IS LOCATED?
NOT WHERE THEY LIVE PREVIOUSLY
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THOSE
LIVING ON DEATH ROWS ARE SERVING
LIFE SENTENCES TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON POLICIES WHAT WHICH THEY
COULD NEVER OUR ROOM WHICH THEY
COULD NEVER RETURN.
EVEN OF PRISONERS RELEASED THEY
MAY NOT EVER GO BACK TO THE CITY
WHERE THEY ONCE LIVED.
SINCE THEY USE WATER AND SEWER
RESOURCES AS THEY PAY SALES TAX
IN THE PLACES WHERE THERE PRISON
IS LOCATED THEY SHOULD BE READY
FOR TO VOTE IN THOSE AREAS.
BUT MISTER SPEAKER.
THIS SPECIFICALLY THE AMENDMENTS
THERE ADDED TO THIS ONE MAKE
THIS FROM A PROBLEMATIC BILL TO
EVEN MORE OF A PROBLEM OF THE
BILL.
IT REQUIRES THE CDC ARE TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION THAT IT
MAINTAINS ABOUT IT FROM INMATES
PRIOR RESIDENTIAL DRESSES
INSTEAD OF PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE INMATES
LAST KNOWN PLACE OF ADDRESS
WHICH WAS PASSED IN THE PREVIOUS
A VERSION OF THIS BILL.
IN OTHER WORDS THIS BILL GOES
FROM TRYING TO COUNT PRISONERS
FROM THEIR LAST KNOWN ADDRESS TO
BEING LITERALLY ALL OVER THE MAP
IT COULD BE THERE PREVIOUSLY
KNOWN ADDRESS OR THEIR PREVIOUS
PREVIOUS. FOR PREVIOUS PREVIOUS
OR MAYBE WHERE THEY'RE BORED.
FROM READING IN REVIEWING THIS
BILL IT DOES NOT MAKE IT CLEAR
WHERE EXACTLY THESE FOLKS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE COUNTED.
MISTER SPEAKER THEY SHOULD JUST
SIMPLY BE ACCOUNTED WHERE THEY
ARE WHERE THEY'RE ENUMERATED
WHERE THEY ARE COUNTED TODAY
THEY SHOULD BE ACCOUNTED AT THE
PRISON WHICH THEY'RE LOCATED.
I URGE A NO VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS AND A NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM DOCTOR
WHEREVER YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH YES MISTER SPEAKER I AS
WE'VE EXPLAINED MANY TIMES AND
COMMITTEE THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE
CENSUS AND IS ABOUT COUNTING
INDIVIDUALS ONCE.
AND WE'RE COUNTING THEM AT THEIR
PLACE OF RESIDENCE IN TERMS OF
THAT WHERE THEIR INCARCERATED IT
IS NOT ABOUT WHERE THEY VOTE OR
WHERE THEY REGISTER TO VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE
VOTES SO THAT THE WEAKENED
OBVIOUSLY MAKE OUR SENSES
COUNTING IS A PROCESS MOVE IT'S
BEEN SUPPORTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER WITHOUT
CLERK WILL OPEN.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER TO
SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLES HIGH
ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE NO
SEVENTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN IS AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY THREE CORPORAL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACTUALLY TO LAND USE
[inaudible]
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY THREE IN THE SENATE DID
THE FOLLOWING CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF DESIGNATED
HISTORICAL RESOURCES TO ENSURE
THAT PROJECTS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PARKING REDUCTIONS COMPLY WITH
ALL FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
ALTERNATIVE REGULATIONS AND
STANDARDS.
NECESSARY FOR THE PRESERVATION
RESTORATION OR CONTINUED USE OF
THE DESIGNATED HISTORICAL
RESOURCE AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THROUGH RESEARCH SIXTY THREE IS
RECEIVED WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
ON ITS WAY HERE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES FRIEDMAN SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY
FOUR NO SIXTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AS AB TWENTY
TWO ANYONE COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY THE CLINICAL
LABORATORIES.
MISTER WHEN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY ONE IS BACK ON
THE FLOOR FOR CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW MEDICAL LABORATORY
TECHNICIANS.
TO PRACTICE THE SKILLS THEY ARE
TRAINED FOR AND THAT THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER STATES ARE
ALREADY PERFORMING.
THE BILL PASSED THE FULL
ASSEMBLY FLOOR UNANIMOUSLY AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE ONE
ADDITIONAL LAB TEST OF MODERATE
COMPLEXITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EYES.
THANK YOU MR Y..
SE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORP LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE EYES.
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCACY.
DOCTORATE MANY MAIL BUT I THINK
YOU'RE SPEAKER THIS BILL IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE DEALING WITH
PATIENT RIGHT ADVOCATES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME AYE VOTE.
SEEN NOTICE CATCHER DEBATE ON
THE ADAM.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
UNDECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A SAD EVENT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED AYE SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD AND FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO YEARS AB TWENTY FOUR
ELEVEN COOPERATE AS A LEGAL
TWENTY FOUR ELEVEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER MCCARTY AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE SOLID WASTE.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
MEASURES ABOUT THE STATE
ENGAGING IN FURTHERING
COMPOSTING WITH STATE PROJECTS
IT'S BACK WITH CLARIFYING SENATE
AMENDMENTS ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS REGARDING THE
SAME NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
HARTWELL HOPE THE ROLL-ON THIS
OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE IN THE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
EYES SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. ONE
OF PASS RETAIN FILE I'M.
TWENTY THREE HE BRINGS US FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
PROJECTS AUTHORIZED BY THIS BILL
TO ONE PROJECT.
PER YEAR FOR ORANGE COUNTY AND A
TOTAL OF TWELVE PROJECTS BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FOR THE DISTRICT.
FURTHER RAIL IT ALLOWS ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC WORKS EMPLOYEES TO
PERFORM PROJECT DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES AND PREPARATION OF
DOCUMENTS THIS BILL WILL ALL
ALLOW FOR AN EXPEDITED PROJECT
DELIVERY IN SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS.
ESPECIALLY FOR A NUMBER OF
PENDING STORM WATER AND FLOOD
CONTROL PROJECTS IN ORANGE
COUNTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARP WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
AND MEMBERS VOTE.
WHOSE OUR THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIDE THAT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE IS AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
NINE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER
CABALLERO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PHARMACY.
MISS COMING ERA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT
CONCURRENCE THE BILL WILL
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY.
AVAILABILITY OF SAFE STORAGE
DEVICES IN PHARMACIES THE SENATE
MADE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO
BROUGHT BY DEFINITION OF SAFE
STORAGE PRODUCTS AND EXCLUDED
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECT REALLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
NAMES CABALLERO SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
INTEL I VOTE I SHOULD THE FIVE
KNOWS TO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE.
WHEN THEY HEARD IN?
MOVING TWO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN AB THIRTY SIXTY NINE IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB
[inaudible]
THIRTY SIXTY NINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AND
ACTUALLY THE CANNABIS
[inaudible]
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SENTIMENTS CLARIFY THEY
MANUFACTURE RETAILER CULTIVATOR.
APPLY THE CANVAS PRODUCT
[inaudible]
TRAINING.
THE PRODUCT WAS DELIVERED TO THE
SITE BY LICENSE DISTRIBUTOR R.
SPEC WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON WHO'S OUT OF
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW YOU THAT AYE
SIXTY AT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I SEE A FORMER MEMBER OF
THIS HOUSE THE HONORABLE SHANNON
GROVE HAS JOINED US WELCOME BACK
TO THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE CONCURRENCE
FILE TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY WHERE TO MOVE BACK TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED BY MR MAIENSCHEIN.
AND THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED BY SOME THE NUMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
THIS ARRANGEMENT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED WAS AMENDED
IN THE SENATE TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO BENEFIT HOUSEHOLDS
WITH FINANCIAL NEEDS FOR REDUCE
COSTS SERVICES.
THANK YOU AND I OUT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS MAJOR SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARCLUB LURE ALL.
MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
BACK IN.
PREVIOUS BORDER THIS IS THE
CONCURRENCE FILE.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY EIGHT FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE
CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE WHAT AT THE
SECRETARY OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES.
AGENCY TO THE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD
WHEN THE BOARD IS CONSIDERING
LAND ACQUISITIONS OR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS UNDER THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THIS
CHANGES INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
THE BOARD MEMBER CAN SPEAK TO
ANY RESOURCES.
OR CONSERVATION GOALS OF A
PROJECT SUCH AS RESOURCES
MANAGEMENT PROTECTION OF OPEN
SPACE OR PROVIDING RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES SENATE AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OF THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BETTER DECIDE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE AYES SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IMPORT FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE A. B. THIRTY ONE
NINETY FOUR CARPOOL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE NINETY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY HOUSING.
MISTER DALY THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL MAKES CHANGES TO THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE
INTENT OF THE BILL.
THOSE AMENDMENTS REFLECT
COMPROMISE LANGUAGE WHICH LEAD
TO THE REMOVAL OF OPPOSITION BY
ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT GROUPS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
HIS ARAGO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLLING TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS
THIRTY SEVEN THROUGH THIRTY NINE
WILL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WERE TO MOVE TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS FORTY FORTY ONE PASS
RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
FORTY TWO ACR TWO FIFTY NINE BY
MISTER GALLAGHER THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWO FIFTY NINE BY SOME THE
NUMBER GALLAGHER AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO PEDIATRIC ACUTE
ONSET NEURO PSYCHIATRIC SEND
YOUR PANTS AWARENESS DAY
[inaudible]
MISTER GALLAGHER.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT.
ACR TWO FIFTY NINE WHICH
DESIGNATES OCTOBER NINTH AS PANS
AWARENESS DAY.
PEDIATRIC ACUTE ONSET NERO
PSYCHIATRIC SYNDROME PANS IS AN
AUTOIMMUNE DISORDER THAT IF LEFT
UNTREATED.
RESULT IN DEVASTATING SYMPTOMS.
DURING AN INFECTION LIKE STREP
THROAT ANTIBODIES WILL
MISTAKENLY BEGIN ATTACKING PARTS
OF THE BRAIN.
JUST DAYS LATER CHILDREN CAN
HAVE A DRAMATIC ON SET OF
NEUROLOGICAL SYMPTOMS.
LIKE OBSESSIVE COMPULSION
AGGRESSION AND ANXIETY.
IT IS OFTEN MISDIAGNOSED AS A
PSYCHIATRIC DISORDER LIKE
TOURETTE.
BUT AND DUE TO THE LACK OF
RESEARCH IN AWARENESS WHICH CAN
LEAD TO AN INADEQUATE TREATMENT.
AND DEBILITATING ILLNESS.
THROUGH THE EFFORTS OF FAMILIES
AFFECTED PANTS HAS RECENTLY BEEN
ESTABLISHED AS A DISTINCT
DIAGNOSIS BUT THERE IS STILL A
LOT OF RESEARCH TO BE DONE AND A
LOT OF WORK.
AHEAD OF US.
IT STARTS WITH SPREADING
AWARENESS OF PANTS IN ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE ARE TRAINED --
THE DOCTORS ARE TRAINED AT TO
RECOGNIZE THIS UNIQUE AND AN
RARE DISEASE THANK YOU.
ASKED WE RECOGNIZE --
PANS AWARENESS DAY IN THIS
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER MISTER
LIVING WE ARE RECOGNIZING YOUR
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
ALSO RISE AND SUPPORT OF ACR TWO
FIFTY NINE WHICH RECOGNIZES
OCTOBER NINTH. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS PEDIATRIC YOU ON SET
NEW SEEK YOU NEAR A PSYCHIATRIC
SYNDROME OR PANTS AWARENESS DAY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
LIKE THE OTHER NEARLY SEVEN
THOUSAND DISEASES AND CONDITIONS
CONSIDERED RARE BECAUSE THEY
AFFECT FEWER THAN TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND AMERICANS PANTS SUFFERS
ARE OFTEN MISDIAGNOSED.
IN A GIVEN TREATMENT THAT DO NOT
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING.
INFECTION MEMBERS THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUFFER FROM RARE
DISEASES IN IS BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO RARE THIS RARITY.
THAT THEY ARE OFTEN CONFLATED
WITH MORE COMMON DISEASES THAT
CAUSE SIMILAR SYMPTOMS WITHOUT
PROPER DIAGNOSES INAPPROPRIATE
TREATMENT PANTS CAN RESULT IN
DEBILITATING CONDITIONS.
THAT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THE LIVES OF THOSE AFFECTED
BY RAISING AWARENESS ABOUT THE
USE RARE DISEASES PATIENTS
CAREGIVERS AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
CAN BETTER RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS OF PANTS AND ENSURE
THAT THE NEARLY 1% OF PEDIATRIC
POPULATION IN THE U. S.
SUFFERING FROM PANTS RECEIVES.
THE PROPER AND NECESSARY
TREATMENT I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MISTER GALLAGHER WAS LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
YES YOU SEE I LIKE TO LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS AND I THINK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM MARIN FOR
JOINING IN THIS --
AND SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER.
MEMBERS THE FIRST ROLE WE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS THIS CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS WE SHOULD ADD AS CO
AUTHORS CO AUTHORS AN ACR.
TO FIFTY NINE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND MISTER GALLAGHER
BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN THE
GALLERY TODAY WE HAVE DOCTOR
RUSSELL SHAPIRO --
DOCTOR SHAPIRO WAS.
SOMEONE WHO'S HELPED MAKE ME
AWARE OF PANTS --
AND AND THIS DEBILITATING
DISEASE IN.
AND HE SHARED WITH ME HIS STORY
OF HIS DAUGHTER.
I'M IT WHO HAS PANTS AND WENT
THROUGH THIS AND THOSE.
STRUGGLES THAT THEIR FAMILY WENT
THROUGH AND ENSURING THAT SHE
WAS DIAGNOSED PROPERLY.
AS SINCE SINCE THAT DIAGNOSIS
DOCTOR SHAPIRO HAS FORMED A
GRASSROOTS EFFORT CAL PANS TO
RAISE AWARENESS SUPPORT RESEARCH
AND ADVOCATE FOR LEGISLATION TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES.
AND CHILDREN WITH BANDS I LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE HIM IN THE GALLERY
DOCTOR SHAPIRO
.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY THREE ACR.
ONE NINETY TWO THE COOPERATE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SALAS AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES
DAY [inaudible]
MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT ACR
ONE NINETY TWO TO DECLARE
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS GOLD STAR
MOTHERS AND FAMILIES DAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND RECOGNIZING GOLD STAR
MOTHERS AND FAMILIES WE HONOR
THE MEMORY A FALLEN SOLDIERS FOR
THEIR BRAVERY AND SACRIFICE.
AND PAID TRIBUTE TO THE
UNTHINKABLE LOSS THE GOLD STAR
MOTHERS AND FAMILIES IN YOUR THE
UNITED STATES BEGAN OBSERVING
GOLD STAR MOTHERS DAY ON THE
LAST MONDAY OF SEPTEMBER IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX WE HONOR THE
MOTHERS AND DAUGHTERS FATHERS
AND SONS HUSBANDS AND WIVES WHO
HAVE WATCHED THEIR LOVED ONES
LEAVE TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY.
ONLY TO SEE THEM FOR THE LAST
TIME.
AND DEEP AND ABIDING GRATITUDE
OUR HEARTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
THE SOLDIERS WHO GAVE THEIR
LIVES IN DEFENSE OF OUR FREEDOM.
AND WITH THE FAMILIES WHO LIVE
WITH THEIR ABSENCE.
THE START OF THE WAR ON TERROR
MORE THAN 690-060-00900 MEMBERS
OF THE UNITED STATES ARMED
FORCES.
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES.
WITH ACR ONE NINETY TWO WE COME
TOGETHER STAND FIRMLY WITH A
GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES.
TO RECOGNIZE THEIR LOST LOVED
ONES AND KEEP THEM IN OUR
MEMORY.
NEVER FORGETTING THE COST OF
FREEDOM.
I REQUEST THAT THE FIRST ROLE
RESPECTFULLY BE OPENED FOR
COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS MR ACOSTA
YOUR RECKON AXED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SAW AS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR ON THIS OF RESOLUTION I
ASKED OBVIOUSLY FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
ABOUT I WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
--
THE FACT THAT THE OF THE MATTER
IS IS THAT SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY DON'T NO A GOLD STAR
FAMILIES ARE I GET ASKED ABOUT
THE LAPEL PIN --
THIS IS A CLUB THAT NO ONE WANTS
TO BELONG TO AS AS MY COLLEAGUE.
OF FROM OUT OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY POINTED OUT SO APTLY WE
SEND OUR LOVE ONES OFF TO WAR --
AND TO SERVE THEIR NATION AND
HOPE TO SEE THEM AGAIN --
AND OFTENTIMES ALL WE RECEIVED
BACK IS A KNOCK AT THE DOOR.
AND THAT IS A ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS THAT THAT YOU'LL NEVER
FORGET IT FOREVER ETCHED IN
INGRAINED IN YOUR MIND --
BUT IT IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT WE
LOOK TO AS A POINT OF PRIDE AND
THAT IS THAT OUR LOVED ONES DID
NOT DIE IN VAIN.
OUR LOVED ONES DIE DOING
SOMETHING THAT THEY TRULY WANTED
TO DO AND I FELT THAT THEY'RE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I
ALWAYS CARRY WITH ME AND I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THIS
BODY BUT ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE GAS AND ALLOW
--
MISTER SALAS TO TO TO READ.
WELCOME THEM BUT THE FACT
REMAINS THAT WE ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER ANNIVERSARY TODAY AND
THAT IS SOMETHING AS WE
CELEBRATE THE ONE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF WOMEN BEING ABLE
TO SERVE IN THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS WE CELEBRATE THAT
TODAY.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO HONOR THE SACRIFICE
MADE.
MALES IN OUR SOCIETY THAT WE GO
OFF TO SERVE BUT WE DO HAVE A A
A A PERCENTAGE OF OF WOMEN THAT
HAVE ALSO PAID THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE AND INCLUDING IN THE
MARINE CORPS.
AND SO WE NEED TO HONOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL I THINK
YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA.
MR BRO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO SUPPORT OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
BAKERSFIELD AND SENATE KARINA.
REGISTER CHERYL STORY MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER AGNES SHEA WAS ALIVE
UNTIL OF SIX AND HER SON MY
GREAT UNCLE DONALD BURROWS
KILLED IN FRANCE IN SEPTEMBER
FORTY FOUR SO UNFORTUNATELY SHE
WAS A MEMBER THE GOLD STAR
MOTHERS OF ORGANIZATION --
BUT IT ALSO REMINDS US THAT IT'S
NOT JUST THE SOLDIERS.
THE FAMILIES TO CARRY ON AN
EXTREME BURDEN --
WHEN THEIR LOVED ONES ARE SONS
AND DAUGHTERS AND HUSBANDS AND
WIVES GO OFF TO WAR SO LET'S NOT
FORGET THE FAMILIES AS WE ARE TO
CONTINUE --
DECADE LONG WAR IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE FAMILIES THAT THERE ARE LOT
OF THE BRUNT NOT WHEN WE'RE IN
THESE CONFLICTS SO.
PLEASE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER BRO.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MISTER SALAS YOU'RE ASKING THAT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THAT IS CORRECT RESEARCH SPEAKER
LET ME JUST SAY --
LET'S RESPECT THE FAMILIES AND
WHAT THEY GO THROUGH AND THE
SACRIFICES THAT THEIR CHILDREN
HAVE MADE FOR OUR COUNTRY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
AMOS ARE CELLS WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON VERSUS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CO AUTHORS.
ON ACR ONE NINETY TWO THIS IS CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
EIGHT COAUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER SALAS BACK
TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS PLEASE --
WELCOME TO THE FLOOR THE SEEING
FAMILY --
CURVE GURPREET SINGH WAS IN THE
FIRST BATTALION OF THE FIFTH
MARINES.
WHERE HE PAID THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE IN JUNE OF TWENTY
ELEVEN OUT IN AFGHANISTAN?
AND SO WITH US TODAY WE HAVE HIS
FAMILY WE HAVE NORMAL SEEING
SUDDEN I'M SAYING MANPREET AND
HER CAR AND HER.
DAUGHTER JAZZ LEAN SO PLEASE
MEMBERS LET'S WELCOME THEM TO
THE FLOOR CHORE GRATITUDE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN FILE
ORDER.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS [inaudible]
FORTY FOUR THROUGH [inaudible]
FORTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR THROUGH.
FORTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY NINE ACR [inaudible]
TWO SIXTY FOUR THE COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIXTY FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER
KALRA ABILITY TO INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY [inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIX FOUR AS OUR BODIES ANNUAL
RECOGNITION OF INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
SIGNIFICANT NATIONAL HOLIDAY IN
INDIA BUT A CELEBRATE RATED BY
MANY INDIAN AMERICANS TO HONOR
THEIR HERITAGE AND CULTURE AND
PAID TRIBUTE. TO INDIA'S
FREEDOMS AND DEMOCRACY.
ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN INDIA PROCLAIMED ITS
INDEPENDENCE SPENDING OVER TWO
HUNDRED YEARS OF BRITISH
COLONIAL RULE.
AS ONE OF THE THREE NATIONAL
HOLIDAYS IN INDIA INDEPENDENCE
DAY IS ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S MOST
IMPORTANT NATIONAL HOLIDAYS.
AND HONORS A INDIA'S EMBRACE OF
DEMOCRACY TOLERANCE OF THE RULE
OF LAW.
HAVE BEEN INSPIRATION EXAMPLE TO
MANY COUNTRIES OF PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD.
THE BIGGEST EVENT OF THE DAY
TAKES PLACE IN DELHI.
WHERE THE PRIME MINISTER RAISES
THE NATIONAL FLAG AT THE
HISTORIC RED FORT?
DELIVERS A NATIONALLY TELEVISED
SPEECH THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE GOVERNMENT.
DISCUSSES CURRENT ISSUES OUR
FUTURE PLANS FOR PROGRESS.
AND PAYS TRIBUTE TO THE LEADERS
OF INDIA STRUGGLE. FOR FREEDOM
WHICH INCLUDES THE ICONIC
MOVEMENT OF NONVIOLENT
RESISTANCE OF CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE
LED BY MAHATMA GANDHI.
WHAT THE POPULATION OF MORE THAN
ONE POINT THREE BILLION PEOPLE?
REPUBLIC OF INDIA IS THE WORLD'S
LARGEST DEMOCRACY.
AND SHE HAS A COMMITMENT TO THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
FREEDOM OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE.
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE DAY SERVES
REMIND US OF THE FOUNDATION OF
ANY NATION AND OUR STATE.
ISN'T AS A PEOPLE IN THEIR
SPIRIT AND COURAGE IN THE FACE
OF ADVERSITY.
AND THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
SACRIFICE THE PURSUIT OF FREEDOM
AND LIBERTY.
AS THE WORLD'S OLDEST DEMOCRACY
AND THE WORLD'S LARGEST
DEMOCRACY RESPECTIVELY.
THE UNITED STATES AND INDIA
SHARE A COMMON VALUES AND THESE
TYPES OF FOSTER GROWTH IN BOTH
COUNTRIES.
AS WELL AS A STRENGTHENING
FRIENDSHIP.
FURTHERMORE THE CALIFORNIA INDIA
RELATIONSHIP IS AN IMPORTANT.
ONE INDIA IS CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S ELEVENTH LARGEST
EXPORT DESTINATIONS DESTINATION
WITH EXPORTS BRIANNE OVER FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY.
ACR TWO SIXTY FOUR HIGHLIGHTS
THE POSITIVE TIES BETWEEN INDIA
AND THE UNITED STATES AS BOTH
SHARE A STRONG VALUES AND
DEMOCRACY AND SERVE AS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
SERVES AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE THEIR HERITAGE AND
HISTORY OF AMERICANS OF INDIAN
DESCENT.
IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT ACR
TWO SIXTY FOUR IN HONOR OF
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE DAY WITH
HOPE TO FURTHER THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND AFFORD ALL CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE THE INDIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES BASS CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR STATE AS WE JUST.
RECOGNIZE WITH OUR GOLD STAR
FAMILY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR AN
AYE VOTE FOR ACR TWO SIXTY FOUR
REQUESTED THE FIRST WILL.
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU
MISTER.
THEY USE THEIR KALRA MISS GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE
THE CITY OF ARTESIA WHICH HAS A
LARGE INDIAN POPULATION IT'S
ALSO KNOWN AS LITTLE INDIA.
OUT OVER THE YEARS I'VE
CELEBRATED A NUMBER OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN THE BUSINESSES
THERE.
WE HAVE THE BEEN THE FAMILY AND
BEEN THE JURY WHICH IS SMALL
BUSINESS OF THE YEAR --
WE ALSO HAVE SINUS HONDA WHO
SPECIALIZES IN AUTHENTIC INDIAN
MADE CLOTHING FOR ALL OCCASIONS.
THEY'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR
OVER THIRTY TWO YEARS AND WE
HAVE SOME OF THE BEST FOOD I
ALSO THERE.
THE TOGETHER IF THEY REMAIN IN
THE IN CONSTITUENTS I WANT TO
SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT INDIAN
INDEPENDENCE.
TODAY WE COMMEMORATE THE
STRUGGLES THAT THE PEOPLE OF
INDIA AND THIRD IN ORDER TO GAIN
THE ABILITY TO GOVERN
THEMSELVES.
TO DECIDE THEIR OWN FATE AND TO
HAVE LASTING GOVERNMENT THAT
REFLECT THE PEOPLE OF INDIA.
THE RIGHT TO HAVE A GOVERNMENT
OF THE PEOPLE.
BY THE PEOPLE IF THEY BELIEVE
THAT THE PEOPLE OF BOTH INDIA IN
THE UNITED STATES UNDERSTAND ALL
TOO WELL.
THE MARKERS THE IS A NEVER
ENDING JOURNEY THAT REQUIRES ALL
OF US TO KEEP WORKING AT IT TO
KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
WHY WILL BE THE FIRST TO CONCEDE
THAT HERE IN THE U. S. AND IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SYSTEMS ARE NOT
PERFECTLY WE HAVE SO MUCH TO BE
THANKFUL?
FOR I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE BECAUSE BY
DOING SO REMINDS US TO
APPRECIATE OUR OWN.
IT ALSO REMINDS US OF HOW TRULY
RICH WE ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THEIR HISTORY AND CULTURE AS
WITH MANY CULTURES THAT HAVE
DECIDED TO CALL THE STATE THEIR
HOME.
ONLY MAKE CALIFORNIA A MORE
VIBRANT COLORFUL PLACE TO BE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CO.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
MR CHEW.
TOYS HIDING BEHIND MY LAMP POST
MY APOLOGIES NOBEL GENERATOR
MUCH AND MISTER SPEAKER.
AND KALIYUGA TODAY ENJOYING MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE IN
CELEBRATING THE SEVENTY FIRST
ANNIVERSARY OF INDIAN
INDEPENDENCE DAY ON AUGUST THE
FIFTEENTH.
I'M FORTUNATE TO REPRESENT A
VERY DIVERSE DISTRICT WHICH
CELEBRATE DIFFERENT CULTURES AND
TRADITIONS.
INDIAN INDEPENDENCE DAY IS A DAY
TO CELEBRATE THOSE WHO FOUGHT
FOR FREEDOM AND HAD THE COURAGE
TO STAND UP.
UP TO STAND UP FOR WHAT THEY
BELIEVE HIM SUCH EXAMPLE IS VERY
INSPIRING ESPECIALLY NOW.
EVERY YEAR DIVERSITY INDEED AT
INDIA INDEPENDENCE DAY PARADE
ORGANIZE BY THE ORGANIZATION
CALLED FAST OF ALL OF TO GO.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF DR JOB
GROWTH.
IN THE CITY ALL FREMONT MY
DISTRICT ENTERED THE BIGGEST ONE
WEST OF THE MISSISSIPPI RIVER.
INDUSTRY YOUR DIFFERING WHAT IS
HAPPENING THIS WEEKEND AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO CELEBRATE
WITH MY CONSTITUENTS AND
COMMUNITY ALL LIKE TO SINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IN THIS
RESOLUTION TO THE FLOOR TODAY.
AND URGE AND I BOTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER KALRA IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLUB CLUB IN THE ROLL.
CALL AUTHORS MEMBERS ON A SPHERE
TO SIXTY FOUR THIS IS CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ADDING. TO
THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER.
THERE SEVENTY THREE CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER KALRA.
BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OB
PURSE I I ONE UP THANK THOSE
THAT MADE IT TO OTHER RECESSION
WE HAD SOME OF THEM ARE STILL IN
THE AUDIENCE AND PLEASE.
STAND OUT OVER SOME OF THE GO
BACK TO WORK SO.
DOES THE AUDIENCE CAN STAND AND
WE ALSO HAD A NUMBER OF INDIAN
AMERICAN STAFF MEMBERS WERE
THERE AND SOME WHO MAY BE.
IN THE GALLERY AS WELL I DO WANT
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK UP CONSUL GENERAL TAKE A
BUS TICKET THEY SENT A SHOCK.
I THINK IT DOESN'T THINK THINK
AT THIS INITIAL IS IN HIS FOURTH
YEAR AND IS.
ARE ENTERING OF THE CLOSE OF HIS
INCREDIBLE ASSIGNMENT WHERE HE'S
BEEN SUCH A WONDERFUL PARTNER.
WE DEVELOPED A GREAT FRIENDSHIP
AND HE'S THE MP SO WELL AND HAS
BUILT A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THOSE OF US.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES --
UNFORTUNATELY HE IS ILL AND ON
HIS BEHALF I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME ALL ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
OUR BEHALF THE CONSUL GENERAL OF
INDIA LOCATED SAMPRAS'S GO WE
HAVE DEPUTY CONSUL GENERAL MR VO
HIT.
ROTH EACH AND THE CONCEPT OF
WHO'S A AT THE CONSULATE
COMMUNITY INFORMATION.
AND CULTURE MRS SUMATHI SECTION
IN A ROW.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
SPECIAL GUEST ON BEHALF OF
CONSUL GENERAL TICKET BASIN A
SHOW TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL GAS THAT HAVE JOINED
US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MR GRAY IF I COULD.
IT'S YOUR ATTENTION THEY BELIEVE
YOU HAVE GAS IN THE CHAMBER.
STERN GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAD TO GET
MY ATTENTION [inaudible]
THE MEMBERS YOU MAY RECALL.
THAT THERE WAS A CRISIS THIS
STATE WAS FACING --
OF NOT HAVING A STATE NOT.
AND MISTER BIGELOW AND I AND THE
REST OF THE MEMBERS OF YOUR
COMMITTEE WORKED HARD TO ENSURE
THAT NOW WE HAVE FOUR STATEMENTS
[inaudible]
AND FOLLOWING THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE STATE NOT.
IT WAS IN CELEBRATION OF THAT
ACTIVITY THAT THE MODESTO NOTS
[inaudible]
BASEBALL CLUB.
WHO ARE PROUD AFFILIATE OF THAT
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL'S SEATTLE
MARINERS CAPTURED THEIR FIRST
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP
LAST YEAR?
CAPPING THE SEASON WITH A SWEEP
OF THE LANCASTER JETHAWKS.
SO MY SYMPATHIES TO MY
COLLEAGUES MR LACKEY MISTER
WELK.
IN TOTAL THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NOTS WENT UNDEFEATED THROUGHOUT
THE POSTSEASON SWEEPING STOCKTON
ON THEIR WAY TO A CHAMPIONSHIP
SERIES.
JO RIZZO WAS NAMED MVP OF THE
SERIES BATTING.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT AND GOING
SEVEN THIRTEEN SEVEN FOR
THIRTEEN WITH A HOME RUN. TO
DOUBLES FOUR RBIS AND THREE
RUNS.
VERY IMPRESSIVE NOT QUITE AS
IMPRESSIVE AS MY STATS AT LAST
YEAR'S SOFTBALL GAME.
BUT WELL DONE.
MODESTO HAS A PROUD IN RICH
BASEBALL TRADITION --
SINCE THE TEAM'S INCEPTION
NINETEEN FORTY SIX NOTS OBSCENE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
FORMER PLAYERS MAKE IT TO THE
MAJOR LEAGUES.
THE CLUB WAS THE ONE TIME HOME
OF HALL OF FAMERS RICKY
HENDERSON.
REGGIE JACKSON AND TONY LARUSSA.
IN TOTAL MODESTO IS ONE NINE
TITLES IN THE CITY SEVENTY YEAR
HISTORY MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A WARM WELCOME FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE CHAMPIONS THE MODESTO
KNOCKED
.
MEMBERS BACK THEN FILE ORDER WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY ACR TWO SIXTY SIX THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT WISHING TO
SIXTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER RUBIO
RELATIVE TO RED RIBBON WEEK.
MS RUBIO YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT ACR.
TWO SIXTY SIX WHICH RECOGNIZES
OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD THROUGH THE
THIRTY FIRST OF THIS YEAR AS RED
BRICK RIBBON WEEK.
AS THE OLDEST AND LARGEST DRUG
PREVENTION PROGRAM IN THE
NATION.
THE RED RIBBON CAMPAIGN REACHES
MILLIONS OF YOUNG ADULTS BY
ENGAGING COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
I'M SURE MANY OF YOU HAVE EITHER
PERSONALLY PARTICIPATED IN RED
RIBBON WEEK OR HAVE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE DONE SO.
BUT YOU MIGHT NOT ALL RECALL HOW
THIS ANNUAL CAMPAIGN STARTED.
THE NATIONAL FAMILY PARTNERSHIP
WHO INITIATED THE RED RIBBON
CAMPAIGN BITS SO AFTER UNITED
STATES DRUG ENFORCEMENT
ADMINISTRATION AGENT BY THE NAME
OF AND LEAKING KIKI CAMARENA.
WAS KILLED BY DRUG TRAFFICKERS
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE SINCE THEN
THIS ANNUAL EVENT HAS BECOME AN
IDEAL WAY. FOR STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES TO UNITE AS ONE TO
TAKE A VISIBLE STAND AGAINST THE
USE AND ABUSE OF DRUGS.
THERE'S THEREFORE I ASKED THAT
YOU ALL DO THE SAME TODAY BY
BOATING AYE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
AND I WOULD LIKE THE FIRST REAL
TO BE OPEN FOR COOPERS.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
FIRST ROLE WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON ACR TWO SIXTY SIX
CARPOOL OPEN ALL.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER AUTHOR SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHOR CHAT A WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
[inaudible] FIFTY ONE THIS IS
ACR TWO SIXTY NINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT SOLUTION TO
SIXTY NINE BY SOME A MEMBER CHOI
AND OTHERS FELT IT DOESN'T
HAUNTING HOLIDAY.
DOCTOR CHOI YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE HOW TO PAY HOME
EACH TWO ONE INCREDIBLE MAN.
WHO CHANGED THE COURSE OF OUR
HISTORY NOT ONLY FOR KOREAN
PEOPLE BUT THE FOR THE WORD?
THIS MAN THE ASSAULT POST.
AND SONG HOLE.
PULLS ON AND TOM O. IS UNKNOWN
AS THOUGHT LEADER.
OF THE KOREAN INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENCE TO MOVE MONTH
DURING THE JAPANESE OCCUPATION
OF FOR KOREA.
HE IT WAS SUCH A STRONG BELIEVER
IN THE POWER OF A MODERN
EDUCATION.
WHICH LED HIM TO ESTABLISH THE
FIRST THE MODERN SCHOOL IN
KOREA.
WITH A DESIRE TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE AMERICAN EDUCATION
SYSTEM HE PACKED.
HIS BAGS TO AND THE MOVE TO A
SAN FRANCISCO.
WHILE IN CALIFORNIA HERE HELP.
THE EARLY KOREAN IMMIGRANTS WHO
CAME TO OUR WORK.
WHY SUGAR PLANTATION?
BECOME A SELF [inaudible]
HELP COMMUNITY.
HE ALSO ESTABLISHED THE OUR
FIRST ORGANIZED A KOREAN
AMERICAN SETTLEMENT.
KOREAN NATIONAL ASSOCIATION AND
ARE YOU LABOR AGENCY.
WHEN KOREA WAS TAUGHT AND NEXT
UP?
BY JAPAN IN.
NINETEEN TEN HE DID NOT TO
HESITATE TO RISE UP TO THE
CHALLENGE OF OUR LEADING THE
KOREAN INDEPENDENCE MOVEMENT.
HIS TOUCH AND FOR ONE SIDE AND
THE AXON SOMEHOW THE KOREANS.
UNDERSTAND THAT AND THE SAME THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF THE OUR FREE
NATION.
AND THEN S. OVERSAW.
DEMOCRACY IS TOUGH FOR ME.
RULE DID DIE IN THE SOUTH KOREA
TODAY.
LET BY HIS SAW CHRISTIAN FAITH.
AND THE LOVE OF GOD AND THE
PEOPLE.
THOUGHT TIME AND TIME HOME TOOK.
TO TO FIGHT FOR HIS PEOPLE.
pIMPRISONMENT BY THE JAPANESE
GOVERNMENT THOUGH FOR YOUR HE
WAS SO TORTURED.
AND ULTIMATELY DIE THOUGH ON
MARCH TENTH [inaudible]
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT HOWEVER.
HIS SON LEGACY LIVE SONG.
IN THE HEARTS OF OUR EVERY
KOREAN PERSON ACROSS THE ROLL
BAR.
A NEW LEGACY M. MOCKED UP BY HIS
SON LEADERSHIP A PHILOSOPHY OF
OUR SOMETHING AYE HE DESCRIBED
AS ARE.
A KEY AT PAR.
WHICH TO ME IS OUT LOVE LIKE
YOURSELF.
LOVE FOR ALL OF THOSE.
I ASK THAT THE FIRST ROAD BE
OPENED THE FOR COAL OFFICE AND
THEREFORE YOUR AYE VOTE THOUGH
ONE RECOGNIZING NOVEMBER NINTH
OF THIS YEAR.
AND THE YEAR AFTER S. OPALS I'M
I'M TOM WHOLE DAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOUG CHOI MISS QUIRK
SILVA YOUR RECORD [inaudible]
KERR.
BUT DOES SON ON JUNHO IS
REGARDED AS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT PATRIOTIC FIGURES BY
KOREANS AT HOME AND ABROAD AND
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I REPRESENT.
A LARGE.
AMOUNT OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
WHAT A PARK IN PART OF MY
DISTRICT AS KOREAN AMERICANS WE
ARE ALSO VERY PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT THEY HAVE DONE IS THEY HAVE
INVESTED IN OUR COMMUNITIES. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I HAVE GEN
CON MEN WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
IRVINE.
IS THE BELIEF THAT EDUCATION
MAKES A HUGE IMPACT IN ALL OF
OUR LIVES NOT ONLY AMERICANS BUT
OF COURSE I IMMIGRANTS WHO COME
TO OUR COUNTRY.
WHAT WE THINK IS ESPECIALLY
GREAT ABOUT DOSE ON ON YOUNG
CHAU IS IS INVESTMENT IN RUN
RETURNING TO KOREA HE FORMED A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS TO LEAD
KOREA'S STRUGGLE AGAINST
JAPANESE ANNEXATION WELL?
HE IN IS HIS WIFE REMAINED IN
AMERICA WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
HE ALSO RAN ON AN AMERICAN
MISSIONARY RUN SCHOOL IN AMERICA
THE MILITARY.
THE MILLER ACADEMY.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT HE
WORKED.
IN RECOGNITION AS A LEADER AND
JAPANESE PRISONS AND WHERE HE
SADLY DIED IN PRISON IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT BUT HIS
LEADERSHIP SPIRIT STILL LIVES ON
IN THE MINDS OF KOREAN NATIONALS
IN KOREAN AMERICANS.
HE HAD A DAUGHTER SUSAN AND SO
YOU CAN SEE THAT --
SHE FOLLOWED HER FATHER'S
FOOTSTEPS AND BEING A FIGHTER
AND SHE WAS INSPIRED HER BY HER
FATHER'S LEGACY AS AN
INDEPENDENCE FIGHTER FOR CREA.
WITH THAT JOIN ME IN HONORING
THIS GREAT MAN BY RECOGNIZING
HIS MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS BOTH
HERE IN AMERICA AND IT IS NATIVE
HOME OF KOREA.
AND I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE AND
INVITING YOU TO RECEPTION AND
ROOM ONE TWENTY FIVE UPON
ADJOURNMENT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
DOCTOR CHEN.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OUR
MEMBERS ARE RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF ACR.
TWO SIX NINE THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE FOR BRING
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
FOR IT SUPPORTS HONOR DON'T ON
ON CHIANG HO IS A PIONEER THE
KOREAN INDEPENDENCE MOVEMENT.
HE ESTABLISHED A YOUNG CREAN
ACADEMY WHICH IS STILL OPERATING
IN SAN FRANCISCO TODAY TO HELP
CREATE AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS TO
COME TO AMERICA TO UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE.
OF A FREE NATION.
TODAY DEMOCRACY IS DEEPLY ROOTED
IN SOUTH KOREA AND I'M PROUD TO
HONOR THOSE ON ON CHIANG HO.
WHO PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE AND
CULTIVATING MODELS AND ETHICS TO
HELP BUILD INNER STRENGTH?
COMMUNITY CONSCIOUSNESS AND GOOD
CITIZENSHIP.
MEMBERS I HOPE WE ASK HER AYE
VOTE FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARISES A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF ACR.
TWO SIX NINE HISTORICAL
REFERENCES TO IRAN'S ACTIVITIES
IN THE UNITED STATES RARELY
MENTIONED RIVERSIDE.
BUT RIVERSIDE WAS KEY.
THE KOREAN INDEPENDENCE
MOVEMENT.
WERE VISITORS REFERRING TO THE
IMMIGRANT SETTLEMENT AS DOSANJH
REPUBLIC.
ON CHIANG HO ARRIVED IN
RIVERSIDE ON MARCH TWENTY THIRD.
NINETEEN OH FOUR AND ESTABLISHED
A KOREAN LABOR BUREAU.
WHICH WAS KEY TO ATTRACTING
KOREAN WORKERS TO THE CITY.
KEY AMONG THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
WAS THE KOREAN NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION.
WHICH OF THE NATIONAL CONVENTION
IN RIVERSIDE IN.
NINETEEN ELEVEN RESEARCH BY
UCR'S YOUNG  KIM CENTER FOR
KOREAN AMERICAN STUDIES.
RESULTED IN THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE DECLARING THE SITE.
AS THE NATION'S FIRST KOREATOWN.
POINT OF CULTURAL INTEREST.
ON DECEMBER SIXTH.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTY THE
RESOLUTION RICK'S RECOGNIZES BUT
CHOP A CAMPSITE.
THE FIRST ORGANIZED KOREAN
AMERICAN SETTLEMENT.
STATUE HONORING ON AS A PATRIOT
IN THE KOREAN INDEPENDENCE
MOVEMENT STANDS IN DOWNTOWN
RIVERSIDE.
AND CONTINUES TO CONNECT PEOPLE
OF KOREAN DESCENT AROUND THE
WORLD.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA MISTER
PATTERSON YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
THANK YOU SPEAKER UP MEMBERS I
TO AS A CO AUTHOR RISE.
OF FOR THIS VERY SPECIAL
CELEBRATION. TO HONOR TO SIGN ON
JUNHO -- HE
LIVED UP MUCH OF HIS EARLY LIFE
IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND SO WE
ARE.
PLEASED TO JOIN WITH SO MANY
OTHERS FROM RIVERSIDEAND OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE SHARED DIE.
EARLY IN HIS LIFE AND FRESNO AND
I REMEMBER --
BACK A FEW YEARS WHEN I WAS A
STUDENT FRESNO STATE UNIVERSITY.
LEARNING OF THIS MA'AM AND
PATRIOTISM.
A L. AND OUR UNIVERSITY SO WELL.
HIS UP.
PATRIOTISM A HIS LEADERSHIP.
I IS KNOWN NOT ONLY ACROSS THE
WORLD BUT ALSO HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS TOUCHED SO
MANY.
OF OUR REGIONS WHERE KOREAN
AMERICANS HAVE ESTABLISHED
THEMSELVES AND HAVE DONE SUCH A
WONDERFUL JOB IN BEING OUR
FRIENDS.
I'D CO WORKERS AYE IN
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND SO I TO JOIN WITHOUT.
OTHERS IN ASKING ABOUT THAT
THAT.
YOU VOTE IN THE AFFIRMATIVE AND
SUPPORT THIS OUT.
A VERY WORTHY RECOGNITION OF
THIS KOREAN PATRIOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED.
DOCTOR CHOI.
YOU MAY CLOSE ON THE RESOLUTION
IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ARE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE IDEA HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND ALSO JOINING IN THE
COLD OR FLU.
THANK GOD CHOI WITHOUT CLUB WILL
OPEN THE ROLE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS IS CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CO AUTHORS ON A C. R.
[inaudible]
TO SIXTY NINE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MEET TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED DOCTOR CHOI BACK TO
YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOUR SPEAKER ARE TODAY
HAVE A WE HAVE A LARGER NUMBER
OF WHILE KOREAN AMERICANS SUCH
JOINING ON THIS AYE HIS STORY
BECAUSE THEY KNOW RECOGNIZE
SYMBOLS AND I'M TOWN POLL --
AND ARE.
ON THE FLOOR AND LET ME
INTRODUCE [inaudible]
VIP'S.
MR ONE JONES TIM IS SOFT
REPUBLIC OF KOREA CONSULATE
GENERAL.
IN LOS ANGELES AND A MISTER JIM
IN TIM DEPUTY BECAUSE A LOT OF
OUR OF KOREA STATIONED IN SAN
FRANCISCO AYE AND MISSED A
PAYPHONE CREW KINDS ON ALL FALL.
REPUBLIC OF KOREA STATION AND
NOT LOS ANGELES UNFORTUNATELY
THE GRANDSON OF A CLOSE AND I'M
TOM HOLE ON MISTER.
ROGERS ON WAS FORCED TO JOIN US
TODAY BUT NOT HIS CELL OVER
NINETY YEARS OLD.
ARE COULDN'T JOIN YOU ARE TODAY
EDITION ON THE JOINING US ARE IN
THE GALLERY --
TODAY ARE AWESOME EDITION OF THE
SPECIAL.
GUESTS --
AMONG THEM OF SOME LEADERS OF
THE COMMUNITY AS I NAME YOU AND
OR THEY ARE OR STANDING UP THE
AIRWAVES YOU AND ARE --
SAYS TO CALL UPON THE SOME OF
THE LEADERS OUT OF YEAH IT'S
FEDERATION OF A GREEN AMERICANS
SOME IS SO.
ARE SINGLE KIND --
KOREAN AMERICAN YOU'D ORPHALI IS
SUPPRESSED AND SACRAMENTO
VALLEY.
A KOREAN AMERICAN YOU NEED.
TO MISTER --
COME MISS SCHOOL [inaudible]
COOL P..
KIM MISQUOTED TO PASS A PRESS
AND UP A KOREAN NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION I'M MEMORIAL
FOUNDATION.
AND A PROFESSOR OF TOM ON JAY
IDEAS SO FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY PRESS NO --
AND OF MISTER POOR MEN PRESS
THEM OF FOLK WHOSE HARD DONE --
IS DONE OVER A PATRIOTIC
ORGANIZATION WHICH WAS TO FORM
THE BY.
BECAUSE I'M ON SOME HOLE --
IN THEIR DISH ON THE REST OF THE
PEOPLE.
I I WANNA SEE MY WITH HIGH --
BY JUST SO --
LETTING THEM KNOW THAT THEY ARE
STANDING UP THE A LARGE NUMBER
--
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HERE --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THOUGHT
THEY'D HAVE COME.
FAR AWAY AND ALSO WIDELY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CAR.
AND UP TO COMMEMORATE DOT THERE
SO HISTORIC LOCATION PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THIS A SPECIAL
GAS.
AND I WELCOME ALL TO JOIN US ALL
FOR SPECIAL RECEPTION UPON WHICH
ON MONDAY --
OF DECEPTION IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH BACKUP
[inaudible]
FILE ORDER.
WHERE TO PASS A RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM?
FIFTY TWO THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE HR UL.
HR.
ONE NINETEEN CORKERY HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE NINETEEN BY SOME
A MEMBER KALRA RELATIVE TO DO
ALI [inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
HOUSE RESOLUTENESS SOLUTION ONE
NINETEEN RECOGNIZES THE
RELIGIOUS AND HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE VALLEY.
PERMISSION TO USE A PROP
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
CELEBRATED BY HINDUS JAMES IN
SEEKS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AS A
RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL FESTIVAL.
THE VOLLEY IS POPULARLY KNOWN AS
BECAUSE IT INVOLVES THE LIGHTING
A SMALL CLAY LAMPS OR IDEAS LIKE
ON HOLDING HERE.
IN MY HAND. TO SIGNIFY THE
TRIUMPH OF GOOD OVER EVIL LIGHT
OVER DARKNESS.
ON THE VOLLEY MY FATHER AND I
ACTUALLY LIGHT.
CANDLES OR LAMPS ALL THE WAY
DOWN OUR WALKWAY INTO OUR HOME.
AYE AND KEEP ALL THE LIGHTS IN
OUR HOUSE LIT UP FOR TWENTY FOUR
HOURS.
THIS YEAR DEVALUE FALLS ON
WEDNESDAY NOVEMBER SEVENTH.
IT IS OF GREAT SIGNIFICANCE TO
INDIAN AMERICANS AND SOUTH ASIAN
AMERICANS BECAUSE THIS CONSIDERS
IT IS CONSIDERED INDIA'S MOST.
POURTANT HOLIDAY OF THE YEAR.
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO SAVE
THIS VIA.
THAT I'D OF HAD DROPPED OFF AT
ALL OF YOUR OFFICES TO LIGHT ON
THIS IMPORTANT DAY NOVEMBER
SEVENTH.
WHAT BETTER WAY TO DISPEL THE
DID THE DARKNESS OF ANGER?
CONTENTIOUS CONTENTION GRUDGES
AND FEAR.
THEN THE DAY AFTER THIS YEAR'S
GENERAL ELECTION WITH A LIGHT.
OF PEACE COURAGE UNDERSTANDING
[inaudible]
AND FORGIVENESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT.
THAT WOULD ASK THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MS GARCIA
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU I THINK SUPPORT OF HR
ONE NINETEEN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER I HAVE.
LITTLE IN THE AND MY COMMUNITY
AND SO THIS HOLIDAYS AND IMPORT
AND I DAY IN MY DISTRICT BUT
ALSO RISE BECAUSE THE WHAT IFS
SYMBOLIZES.
IF THE TRIUMPH OF LIGHT OVER
DARKNESS IN TIMES LIKE THOSE
THAT WERE LIVING TO DAY AT SOME
POINT IN THAT WE FIND WHATEVER
WAYS WE CAN. TO FIND EACH
OTHER'S HUMANITY SHARON AND
CELEBRATIONS LIKE THEIR WALLETS
IS ONE WAY WE CAN CONNECT.
AND MAKING THAT CONNECTION
THAT'S OUR LIGHTS.
THAT'S HOW WE AS CALIFORNIANS US
AMERICANS WILL OVERCOME THE
DARKNESS.
AND EMBRACE PEACE COURAGE AND
THERE'S UNDERSTANDING AND
FORGIVENESS ARE ARE IN SO MUCH
NEED AT THIS TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS ASKING OF FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON HR ONE NINETEEN THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AS HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR IS
HR.
ONE TWENTY CORPORATE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY BY SOME A
MEMBER CHOI AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO CREATE INDEPENDENCE DAY.
DOCTOR CHOI YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU AGAIN
AND THE MEMBERS.
ARE HR ONE TWENTY RECOGNIZES SO
AUGUST FIFTEENTH TO ASK THE
SEVENTY THIRD.
ANNIVERSARY OF A KOREAN
INDEPENDENCE DAY ALSO KNOWN AS
SAW THE LIBERATION DAY.
ARE KOREANS CALL IT PONTOON BOAT
SHOW OF WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
ARE VOTE REGAINING THE LIE.
AFTER THIRTY SIX YEARS OF OUR
JAPANESE SAW OCCUPATION.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YES SO
HOME TO MORE THAN.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND A KOREAN
AMERICANS SO WHO CELEBRATE
THOUGHT THIS ARE IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
HOLIDAY.
KOREAN LIBERATION THEY PUNK ROCK
JOEL.
R. IS SUCH A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE THE
GREAT DUCK CONTRIBUTIONS.
OF THIS SOUTH KOREAN AMERICANS.
pHOUSE ARE AND REACHED.
THE ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND THE
CULTURAL LANDSCAPE BUBBLE
CALIFORNIA.
I WILL CONTRIBUTIONS COVER THE
ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF INDUSTRIES SO
FROM BUSINESS.
SO POLITICS TO MUSIC TO
ARCHITECTURE TO OUGHT TO
ENGINEERING THE LAW TO
EDUCATION.
YOU NAME IT.
AND THAT WE HAVE MADE OUR OUR
MARK.
VIEWS SUB RESOLUTION ALSO FORM
SONAR UNIQUE A TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF THE KOREAN PEOPLE AS
WE SEE THE UNPRECEDENTED.
OF PEACE TALKS UP BETWEEN NORTH
KOREA AND THE UNITED STATES SOME
ARMOR AMERICA.
SUCCESSFULLY ARE MOVING FORWARD
REPRESENTING THE SOURCE SOLVE
OUR THE GREEK THE WHOLE. FOR
PEACE AND SECURITY THROUGHOUT
THE REGION [inaudible]
KOREAN AMERICANS AND THE KOREAN
THIS ALL AROUND THE WORDS DON'T
HAVE A LOT TO CELEBRATE TALK ON
THIS A SEVENTY THIRD.
ANNIVERSARY OF OUR KOREAN
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
I BELIEVE OUR AUGUST FIFTEENTH
THIS ARE GOOD DAY TO CELEBRATE
OUR MANY NATIONS AYE INDEPENDENT
STATE.
ARE KOREA SIGNED A PEN THE STATE
AND THE OR SO INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY I RESPECT
[inaudible]
WELL.
THIS SAW OUR MANAGER WOULD BE
OPEN THE FOR THE FOR CO AUTHORS.
AND ALL YOU AYE VOTE WOULD BE
APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI DUCKS
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF HR.
ONE TWENTY I WELL REMEMBER AS A
FIRST SECOND AND THIRD GRADER
AND NINETEEN FIFTY ONE FIFTY TWO
AND FIFTY THREE THE HORRORS OF
THE KOREAN WAR [inaudible]
AND IT RESULTED IN A SPLIT STATE
AND I CAN ONLY HOPE.
THAT SOMEDAY SOON THERE'LL BE A
UNITED KOREA AND THINK WE CAN
ALL CELEBRATE TO INDEPENDENCE
DAY TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DUCKED QUIRK MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ALSO
RISE TO US SUPPORT HR ONE TWENTY
AND THANK.
MY COLLEAGUE FONG A RIFLE
BRINGING THIS A VERY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION TO THE FLOOR --
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CITY
OF SANTA CLARA WHICH WE HAVE THE
THE EL CAMINO REAL ALL THE WHOLE
STRUCTURE OF EL CAMINOS RIONE
SAID CITY OF SANTA CLARA.
IS A GOOD CANDIDATE FOR A
DESIGNATION OF A KOREAN TOWN AND
ALL WE ALSO HAVE MANY MANY.
THE A HIGH TECH COMPANY --
LIKE SENSE ON HOW QUARTERS.
AND HIGH NEXT TO IN THE NORSE SO
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ALSO THANK THE KOREAN
AMERICANS FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTION
NOT JUST TO THE LOCAL.
OF BUSINESSES BUT TO DO A THE
WELL BEING AT A AROUND THE WORLD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON THE
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF HR.
ONE TWENTY THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES AUGUST FIFTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NECESSARY
THIRD ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE INDEPENDENCE THE REPUBLIC
CARILLO.
IS A GREAT HONOR TO CELEBRATE
THIS DAY WITH OUR KOREAN
NEIGHBORS AND JOIN THE RICH
CULTURE AND THE KOREAN AMERICAN
POPULATION HAS INSTILLED.
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND KOREAN AMERICANS.
CULTURAL DIVERSITY A RICH IS THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT
ONLY INITIATING GROWTH AND
PROGRESS BUT ALSO A STRONG SENSE
OF COMMUNITY.
ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH WE ARE PROUD
TO CELEBRATE KOREA INDEPENDENCE
KOREAN INDEPENDENCE CULTURE AND
ALL THE WONDERFUL CONTRIBUTIONS.
OF THE KOREAN PEOPLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR.
ONE TWENTY THANK YOU SEEING NO
FURTHER REQUEST TO SPEAK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
METAL SPEAKER THANK YOU WITH ALL
MY COLLEAGUES SO WHO JOIN ME --
WITH A NICE COMMENTS SAW I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THE AND THE
FIRST RULE BE OPEN FOCAL OFFICE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CHARACTERS
MEMBERS THIS ROSE FOR COAUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS IS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION
.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
A VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION HER GOING TO
MOVE TO ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE SP
TWELVE THIRTY NINE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
MULLIN.
THANK YOU WITH SOME NEVER MULLIN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE TO RESOLVE POTENTIAL CHAP
CAPTURING OUT ISSUES WITH THE
MEASURE I AM AUTHORING AB.
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU THE AMENDMENTS ARE IN
PRINT THE ITEMS BACK ON FILE.
MOVING NOW TO THIRD READING
SENATE BILLS ITEM FIFTY FIVE
PASS AND RETAIN ITEM FIFTY SIX
SB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE ELEVEN FORTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THE MEMBERS TO S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE BEFORE YOU TODAY WIL
SIMPLY ADDRESS TECHNICAL CHOPPER
NOW ISSUES.
OUR SPECTER ASKED FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AYE EGGMAN.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM IS BACK IN PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER FROM
MOTIONS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE RETURN ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SALAS
THE SENATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RESCIND THE ACTUAR BY
JULY FIFTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY RED FOR A THIRD TIME S.
B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN SKINNER.
AND PASSED THE BILL TO THE
SENATE PLEASE ORDER THE BILL TO
THE THIRD READING FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
ITEMS FIFTY SEVEN FOR SIXTY FIVE
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM.
SIX S. SJR.
TWELVE MEDICAL PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWELVE
BY SENATOR WIENER RELATIVE TO
INTERNATIONAL EXCHANGE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWELVE
BY SENATOR WIENER.
BECAUSE UPON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO RESTORE RESTORE
FULL FUNDING TO THE FULL BRIGHT
U. S. STUDENT PROGRAM.
FULL BUT THE FULBRIGHT PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO INCREASE MUTUAL
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE PEOPLE
OF UNITED STATES.
AND THE PEOPLE OF OTHER
COUNTRIES.
IS THE FLAGSHIP INTERNATIONAL
EDUCATIONAL EXCHANGE PROGRAM
SPONSORED BY THE US GOVERNMENT.
THIS PROGRAM IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR STUDENTS TO LIVE AND STUDY
ABROAD.
AND EMBARKED ON A CAREER OF
PUBLIC SERVICE.
ALUMNI INCLUDE EIGHTY FOUR
PULITZER PRIZE WINNERS. FIFTY
NINE NOBEL PRIZE RECIPIENTS.
THIRTY SEVEN HEADS OF STATE. TEN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS SENATOR
WIENER HIMSELF AND A HANDFUL OF
OUR OWN LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
A 71% CUT. TO THE FULBRIGHT
PROGRAM APPROPRIATIONS FUNDS.
THIS RESOLUTION SIMPLY URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO RESTORE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO MILLION
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED TO
THE FULBRIGHT PROGRAM.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
YES THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN
THE ROLE FOR CAR.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR COAUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR COAUTHORS.
BUT I'M QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY ONE COOPER
IS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES A ROLL
CALL VOTE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS RULE REQUIRES THAT THIS
ROLE IS.
UP ALTHOUGH ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CREDIT CARD PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES EYES
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
I AM SIXTY SEVEN PER SIXTY NINE
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM
SEVEN S. B..
FIVE THIRTY ONE BETTER PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE MEMBER
EGGMAN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MUCH THAT.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS S. B..
FIVE THIRTY ONE IS A BILL THAT
ADDRESSES ISSUES AROUND THE PORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MANACOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT TO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
I DON'T CLERK.
BUT A BOOK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE BOATS I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT PRINTED
BACK ON FILE.
ITEM SEVENTY ONE THROUGH SEVENTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
ITEM SIX S. B. NINE FORTY SEVEN
BOTTOM QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL NINE FORTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
THURMAN'S.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR S. B..
NINE FORTY SEVEN OF THIS
ESTABLISHES AN ADVISORY PANEL
COMPRISED OF EDUCATION EXPERTS
WHO WORK IN TANDEM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
BEST PRACTICES FOR TEACHING
DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP AND MEDIA
LITERACY.
THE AMENDMENT SIMPLY EXTEND THE
DEADLINE FOR THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE'S REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE FROM DECEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL BE
TAKING A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEMS SEVENTY SEVEN THROUGH
EIGHTY ARE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY ONE S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN MADAME
QUICKLY STREET.
SAMPLE FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
MEMBER IRWIN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER OR WHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AND TO THE
AMENDMENTS S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN OUR TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AND WILL CORRECT A CONFLICT WITH
SENATE BILL TWO TO FOUR BY
SENATOR JACKSON I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST.
THAT THE BILL GO OUT PRETTY BE
PLACED BACK ON THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL BE TAKING A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM AS BACKUP IS BACK ON FILE
AND HOW TO PRINT.
ITEMS EIGHTY TWO THROUGH EIGHTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM EIGHTY SIX PASS
TEMPORARILY.
ITEMS.
EIGHTY SEVEN THROUGH ONE OH TO
PASS AND RETAIN A MOVING TO ITEM
ONE OH THREE SB. THIRTY ELEVEN
THIRTEEN MADAM COURT PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE MEMBER
CARILLO.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREATE
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTEEN BY OUR SENATE COLLEAGUE
FROM CARMEL.
THE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
CONSULT WITH THE LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY OR THE
DESIGNEES TO DEVELOP THE
VOLUNTARY MENTAL HEALTH
STANDARDS DESCRIBED IN THIS
BILL.
I ASK THE AMENDMENT BE ADOPTED
IN THE BILL CLOUT.
TO THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE
[inaudible]
ALL OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM IS BACK IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE THANK YOU
.
ITEMS.
ONE OH FOR THROUGH ONE FORTY
EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN
.
WE ARE MOVING MEMBERS TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND THEY
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER RUBIO AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO BREASTFEEDING
AWARENESS MONTH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WORLD.
FOUNDER ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM COURT PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
SENATE CONCURRENT VERSION.
NINETY ONE I SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
EIGHTY SIX S. B. TENNIS SEVENTY
NINE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
MEMBERS DOWN.
SOME MEMBER STONE YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A MEMBER THE AMENDMENTS
ARE SIMPLY TO ADDRESS THE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS THE TRACKING OF
THE ADVANCE PAYMENTS REPORTING.
THAT THOSE MECHANISMS I ASKED
THAT VOTE I ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE BILL GO BACK IT'S
PRETTY GO BACK ON BY THAT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED THE BILL IS BACK TO
PRINT AND IS OUT TO PRETTY BACK
ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR WE ARE NOT LEFT IN THE
FORM CALL ON THIS ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
MEMBERS I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK.
YOU ALL FOR YOUR VERY --
KIND THOUGHTS AND CONDOLENCES ON
THE PASSING OF MY MOM.
MY MOM MY WAS BORN [inaudible]
AND RICKY.
GOLDSTINE HER SHE WAS THE
DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANTS FROM
EASTERN EUROPE.
AND WAS BORN IN SALEM
MASSACHUSETTS OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE YEARS AGO.
WITH A ONLY A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA SHE LEARNED BOOKKEEPING
AND TO THAT CAME IN REALLY HANDY
BECAUSE SHE BECAME THE
BOOKKEEPER AND HELP MANAGE.
HER PARENTS GROCERY AND THAT AND
AND DELI.
THAT WAS A GOOD THING BECAUSE
SHE MET A YOUNG BOX BOY THERE
NAMED AARON BLOOM --
WHO LATER BECAME HER HUSBAND AND
MY DAD [inaudible]
AGAIN.
HER BOOKKEEPING SKILLS WERE A A
REALLY HANDY TO ALL OF US WHEN I
STARTED MY LAW PRACTICE IN --
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HE KEPT
THE BOOKS FOR ME.
OF SHE RAN HER SYNAGOGUES GIFT
SHOP AND AND KEPT ITS BOOKS.
AND TOGETHER WITH MY FATHER CO
FOUNDED THE ETA CENTER.
UP WHICH IS A NONPROFIT IN LOS
ANGELES THAT TODAY SERVES THE
NEEDS OF HUNDREDS OF
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
ALONG WITH MY DAD AGAIN SHOOT BY
THE WASTED THAT AT THE AGE OF
NINETEEN OF SEVENTY EIGHT
TOGETHER WITH MY DAD SHE
VOLUNTEERED LITERALLY THOUSANDS
OF HOURS.
ATTENDING TO THE NEEDS OF FOR A
SICK INDIVIDUALS AT CEDAR SINAI
HEALTH CENTER.
AND THERE WAS NEVER A SICK
PERSON --
NEVER A FUNERAL THAT MY PARENTS
WOULDN'T TO TEND TO HELP TEND TO
THE OF A TO THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
MY MOM LIVE TO A LIFE OF FOR A
MEANING A LIFE OF PUBLIC
SERVICE.
A IN A LIFE OF FOR OF OF
PURPOSE.
AT RAISING FOUR CHILDREN.
AND LEAVING ELEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
AND I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT COUNT
OF GREAT GRANDCHILDREN THAT --
THAT SHE LEFT --
EVERYBODY --
OF MRS MY MOM BUT UP LET ME TELL
YOU FOLKS SHE WAS TOUGH AS
NAILS.
ON SHE HAD OPINIONS TO MATCH --
AND AND TENACIOUSLY LIKE.
OF ALL OF US HELD ONTO HER
BELIEFS UP SHE DIDN'T SUFFER
FOOLS EASILY.
ON AND IT WAS NOT UNHEARD OF FOR
HER TO BE IN A ROOM.
OF OF PEOPLE AND IF THE SUBJECT
OF POLITICIANS CAME UP.
OF MY MOM WOULD BE THE ONE TO
SAY THEY'RE ALL AND I'D BE IN
THE ROOM.
THEY'RE ALL A BUNCH OF CROOKS.
AND I'VE LOOKED HAGGARD AGO MOM.
SAY EXCEPT FOR YOU.
AND IT WAS A AFTER HAVING SERVED
FOURTEEN YEARS AS A COUNCIL
MEMBER AND AND MAYOR IN SANTA
MONICA.
IT WAS A A VERY EXCITING DAY FOR
BOTH SHE AND I WHEN I WAS
ELECTED --
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN TWENTY
TWELVE BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
SHE WAS MY CONSTITUENT OF SHE
WAS VERY PROUD OF ME AND THE
WORK THAT WE DO HERE.
ON I MISS HER DEARLY AND ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM I'M SURE
I SPEAK TO EVERYBODY WHEN WE SAY
THAT WE'RE VERY SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS.
MEMBERS THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY AUGUST
FOURTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY AUGUST FIFTEENTH
SECOND SESSION THURSDAY AUGUST
SIXTEENTH FLOOR SESSION AND I
AM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOW LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PRE EASLEY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO GERMAN THE
MEMORY OF BILL EDWARDS A BILL
WAS BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY AND
PASSED AWAY ON JUNE TWENTY
SECOND.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS YEAR.
BORN IN TAMPA FLORIDA BILL GREW
UP IN MIAMI BEACH AND LATER
ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
FLORIDA.
AFTER COLLEGE HE JOINED THE NAVY
AND THE STATION AT THE NAVAL
HOSPITAL IN EUROPE THE YOKOSUKA
JAPAN.
HE LEFT THE NAVY IT AND MOVED TO
NEW YORK WHERE HE PURSUED A VERY
DIFFERENT PASSION THE ARTS AND
GRADUATED FROM THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF DRAMATIC ARTS.
BILL THEN MOVED TO LOS ANGELES
TO WORK AT NBC STUDIOS WHERE HE
MET HIS FUTURE WIFE OF FIFTY
YEARS.
HE MOVED FROM BURBANK TO SEAMY
VALLEY IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
AND WENT TO WORK FOR PACIFIC
INSPECTIONS.
AT THE AGE OF FIFTY HOWEVER HE
QUIT HIS JOB WITH THEM TO OPEN
EDWARDS ON STAGE STUDIOS.
WHICH ENDED UP BEING A SEAMY
VALLEY INSTITUTION THE PROVIDED
LOCAL CHILDREN WITH THE LOVE OF
THE ARTS A PLACE TO GO.
BILL RAN THE STUDIO FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS BEFORE RETIRING TO SPEND
TIME WITH HIS CHILDREN AND GRAND
KIDS.
HE CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE IN
ANY AND ALL COMMUNITY EVENTS
THROUGHOUT THE REMAINDER OF HIS
LIFE MOST NOTABLY.
HE WAS AN ORIGINAL DOCENT AT THE
RONALD REAGAN PRESIDENTIAL
LIBRARY AND WAS THE GRAND
MARSHAL OF THE TWENTY FIFTH
ANNUAL SEAMY VALLEY DAYS PARADE.
WHICH HE HAD ATTENDED EVERY YEAR
SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
BILL WAS A WONDERFUL FIGURE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND ITS PRESENCE
IN THE DISTRICT WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN TODAY SESSION.
IN THE MEMORY OF A GREAT MAN
BILL EDWARDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
SANDRA THORN OR SANDY ISSUE IS
KNOWN TO US.
THE FIRST LADY OF PLEASANTON WHO
PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST THIRD
AFTER A BATTLE WITH CANCER.
SANDY WAS BORN IN AUGUST OF
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN IN
CONNECTICUT ONE OF SIX CHILDREN
AND THIS MONTH WOULD HAVE BEEN
HER EIGHTY FIRST BIRTHDAY.
SHE WAS CERTAINLY VERY WELL
KNOWN AS HER UNWAVERING SUPPORT
FOR OUR LOCAL MAYOR IN
PLEASANTON JERRY THORNE THEY
WERE INSEPARABLE AND ALWAYS
TOGETHER AND ALWAYS SUPPORTING
ONE ANOTHER.
I'M AND SHE WAS VERY GIVING AS
THE FIRST LADY OF PLEASANTON BUT
SHE WAS ALSO VERY WELL KNOWN FOR
HER OWN LEADERSHIP AND
PHILANTHROPY IN OUR COMMUNITY AS
WELL.
SHE WAS ON THE WORD OF MUSEUM ON
MAIN WHICH IS A WONDERFUL MUSEUM
IN DOWNTOWN PLEASANTON SHE BEGAN
AS A VOLUNTEER IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR AND LATER WENT ON TO SERVE
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
THE MUSEUM AND LEAD MANY OF ITS.
A MOST SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS. FOR
TO THE COMMUNITY SANDY WAS ALSO
AN AVID SUPPORTER OF THE
ASSISTANCE LEAGUE OF AMADOR
VALLEY WHICH IS AN ALL VOLUNTEER
NON PROFIT ORGANIZATION SERVING
CHILDREN TEENS AND SENIORS
THROUGHOUT THE TRI VALLEY AREA
--
SANDY WAS REALLY VERY VERY
FUNNY.
AND YOU COULD ALWAYS COUNT ON
HER YES SHE WAS IT JERRY SIDE
MAYOR STORE INSIDE --
AND AND VERY SUPPORTIVE OF HIS
TIRELESS WORK FOR THE COMMUNITY
OF PLEASANTON IN THE TRI VALLEY
AREA BUT IN HER OWN RIGHT JUST
HAD A WONDERFUL PERSONALITY VERY
VERY WARM.
VERY GIVING TO THE COMMUNITY FOR
DECADES --
IT WAS.
IT WAS QUITE SUDDEN HER PASSING
WE KNOW THAT SHE WAS BATTLING
CANCER BUT SHE'S SO INCREDIBLY
STRONG IT WAS A IT WAS A SHOCK
TO ALL OF US.
OUR COMMUNITY IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT EMBRACE OF MAYOR JERRY
THORNE AND HIS ENTIRE FAMILY
INCLUDING HIS DAUGHTER AND
GRAND.
WHO LIVING IN SWEDEN AND --
AND ALL OF ALL OF THE FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY WHO HAVE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH THE
GETTING TO KNOW AND LOVE THE AND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
HONORING HER GREAT GREAT MEMORY
TO OUR COMMUNITY.
BY TURNING IN HER MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
YOU RECOGNIZE.
AND I SAID YOU'RE IN MEMORY OF
MISTER MARK MILLER.
MISTER MILLER WAS BORN IN
NOVEMBER TWELFTH NINETEEN FORTY
NINE AND PASSED AWAY ON JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH.
AT THE YOUNG AGE OF SIXTY EIGHT
AND THE EARLY EIGHTY OVERCAME
DOT HE OVERCAME DOCTORS
DIAGNOSED AS THE BEING PARALYZED
FOR LIFE.
FROM THE SPINAL INFECTION BUT
NEVER LET HIS MOBILY MOBILITY
CHALLENGES PREVENT HIM FROM
LEAVING HIS FULLEST LIFE.
MR MILLER BEGAN HIS TEACHING
CAREER RIGHT OUT OF COLLEGE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND BEGAN
AS A CHOIR TEACHER ABOVE OUR
HEADS INTERMEDIATE ALSO KNOWN AS
FIJI I AND MY ALMA MATER.
HE HAS ALWAYS HAD A PASSION FOR
MUSIC EDUCATION LEARNING TO PLAY
PIANO.
DURING THIS TIME AYE BG AYE HE
TOOK A SABBATICAL TO GET A
COUNSELING DEGREE AND WHEN HE
RETURNED HE MET HIS WIFE LAURIE.
WHO WAS COVERING HIS DECISION
WHILE HE WAS AWAY AND THEY WOULD
FINALLY TALK ABOUT HOW THEY MET?
MISTER MILLER SPENT HIS WHOLE
TEACHING CAREER ALL THIRTY SIX
YEARS THAT BOTH GARDEN CENTER
MEDIA.
HE WAS THE CLASSROOM TEACHER A
DRAMA TEACHER ACQUIRE TEACHER
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR.
YEARBOOK AND CO FOUNDED AND
COORDINATE AT THE BELL GARDENS
INTERMEDIATE LEADERSHIP CAM. TO
ENGAGE STUDENTS WITH THEIR
ELECTED INCLUDING AN ANNUAL TRIP
TO THE CAPITOL.
THE SCHOOL OF HIS HOME AWAY FROM
HOME AS HE WOULD OFTEN SAY IF HE
COULD WHO WOULD WANT TO BE
BURIED THERE.
HE STARED THE BELL GARDENS
COMMUNITY HEATH ENTIRE
PROFESSIONAL ADULT LIFE EVEN
AFTER HE RETIRED.
OVER THE YEARS HE MENTORED MANY
STUDENTS AND THAT A CARE WITHOUT
TO EMPOWER EACH STUDENT TO THE
THEIR BEST AND BE SUCCESSFUL.
I THOUGHT THAT PRETTY READY TO
ENCOUNTER A NUMBER OFTHESE
YOUNG STUDENTS HAVE BECOME
LEADERS IN OUR COMMUNITY ALL
ENCOURAGE AND MENTORED AND
SUPPORTED BY.
MR MILLER.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
LAURIE.
DAUGHTER DANA AND SON CAMERON
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH THE FAMILY.
THINKING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY MET SPEAKER UP MEMBERS ON
SUNDAY JULY TWENTY SECOND
MILLARD SUNNY THE LINES PASSED
AWAY.
HE WAS SURROUNDED BY HIS
CHILDREN AND FAMILY.
WHO WERE GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE
LAST FEW WEEKS TOGETHER WITH
HIM?
AND SHARE IN THE MEMORIES F HIS
STRONG FAITH.
SONNY IS THE FATHER OF OUR
FRIEND OUR COLLEAGUE AND FORMER
ASSEMBLY.
MINORITY LEADER MIKE THE LINES.
AND SUNNY LIVED THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
HE MIGRATED WITH HIS FAMILY AND
THE DUST BOWL FROM OKLAHOMA TO
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY.
HE ENLISTED IN THE NAVY AT
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD SERVED
HONORABLY IN THE KOREAN WAR.
AFTER THE WAR HE WENT TO FRESNO
STATE ON THE GI BILL EVENTUALLY
HAD A LONG CAREER WITH THE
RAYTHEON CORPORATION.
IN THE BAY AREA.
SONNY DEEPLY LOVED HIS FAMILY HE
WAS A DEDICATED HUSBAND TO THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE.
AND WIFE OF FIFTY EIGHT YEARS
JONI WHO PRECEDED HIM IN DEATH.
HE WAS ALSO A DEVOTED FATHER TO
HIS THREE CHILDREN JOE MIKE AND
SUSAN.
HE WAS A BASEBALL COACH SOCCER
COACH LITTLE.
LEAGUE BASEBALL REGIONAL
COMMISSIONER AND A BOY SCOUT
LEADER.
SONNY LOVE SPENDING TIME WITH
HIS GRANDCHILDREN CONNIE.
ALISON AND JOSHUA ESPECIALLY
WATCHING FRESNO STATE SPORTS AND
WAS ONE OF THE REASONS HE
RETURNED TO CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
AFTER HIS YEARS WITH RAYTHEON.
TO SPEND TIME WITH HIS KIDS AND
HIS GRAND KIDS.
WAS A PROUD FRESNO STATE
BULLDOGS EVEN PROUDER OF THE
THREE GENERATIONS OF BULLDOGS IN
HIS FAMILY.
SO HE WAS VERY ACTIVE IN HIS
CHURCH THE CHURCH OF JESUS
CHRIST OF LATTER DAY SAINTS.
HE WAS A LOVED VOLUNTEER IN THE
CHURCH AS MANY OUTREACH PROJECTS
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
THE FINAL WEEKS OF HIS LIFE
SONNY WAS SURROUNDED BY FAMILY
FRIENDS HIS CHURCH FAMILY A
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY OF
NEIGHBORS.
HE WILL BE MISSED BY EVERYONE
WHO KNEW HIM HE'D LEAVES A VERY
WARM.
LEGACY YET UP FOR HIS FAMILY AND
FOR HIS OTHERS OTHERS TO FOLLOW
AND ALSO A LEGACY OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO LIVE A LIFE WELL LIVED.
I THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN
SONNY'S THEIR MEMORY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PRESENT PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES TO THE DEATH TO BE PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO
ATTORNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND TO THE JOURNAL.
ALL THEIR ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN A MOTION SO
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY AUGUST SIXTEENTH AT
NINE AM
.
HARPER FILE ITEM TWENTY AB.
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED NO TO HIGH.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HARPER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED NOTES I